these are seven investing Concepts that
will make you money starting with number
one lifetime gross profit compared to
cost to acquire a customer which
basically means how much money you make
in profit from every person who comes
into a business compared to how much it
costs to get them to buy to begin with
this is the fundamental economic unit of
the business you buy attention you buy
eyeballs to get customers and then you
sell those eyeballs something that
you're going to make a profit from all
the profit that gets generated from the
business comes from this one ratio and
so if someone has for example a 1:1
ratio of LTB to CAC they spend a dollar
and they make a dollar back and so
that's it you know let's say let's say a
20 to1 that means for every dollar they
put in they get 20 back as profit this
becomes a business that you can scale
endlessly and becomes an incredibly
attractive business getting really clear
on what your lgp to CAC ratio is is core
to Growing anything so let's define
these terms lifetime gross profit has a
couple of components there's Lifetime
and then there's the gross profit
component so lifetime is like okay well
how many times is someone going to pay
me within a product's business how many
times does someone Buy on average over
the lifespan Shopify stores things like
that will actually just give you this
metric which is like the average
customer buys 4.3 times if you have a
Services business or a membership based
business then it might be the average
lifespan so how many months are they
going to stick with you now if you don't
know this because you might be a smaller
business that doesn't have a CRM that
reports on this kind of stuff I'll give
you the back of napkin way to actually
calculate this how many customers did I
have at the beginning of the month now
of these people people that I had at the
beginning 30 days later what's the
number of those people that I have at
the end not the number of customers in
total cuz you might sell people in
between but I want to know of the people
at the beginning of the month how many
of them are still there 30 days later so
if I had 100 people here at the
beginning and I had 90 people at the end
then I would have 10% turn and you're
like okay wait is that the number no
what we then do is we take one and we
divided by this number which then means
that our average lifespan in this
example would be 10 months or or 10
intervals whatever interval you're
measuring on cuz if I did this quarterly
it would be the same thing or annually
it'd be the same thing number of people
at the beginning 100 number people the
end 90 I lost 10 meaning I have a 10%
churn 1 divid by 10% equals 10 so the
average number of months that someone
stays is 10 months everything that I'm
going to show you today is stuff that
you can do addition subtraction
multiplication or division there's
nothing else you don't have to be a
genius to learn how to invest or build a
business so now that we just covered
lifetime now we need to figure out gross
profit which is how much extra cash do
we have left over from each customer
after we do a transaction the simplest
example I can give you is if this cost
me a dollar and I sell it for $2 then I
have a dollar of gross profit now I
still have to take that dollar and pay
other costs I have to pay rent I have to
pay other fees that go along and then my
margin is now squeezing from that 50%
that was left over until what my net
margin becomes at the end of the day
with widgets or physical products it's
really that simple it's just price minus
cost of good sold and so cost of good
sold are going to be all the costs that
you have to incur specifically related
to delivering the product all you're
trying to figure out is that the basic
transaction how much money you have left
over now with physical products it's
typically much simpler than with
service-based businesses but I'm going
to give you a service-based example so
you can still understand it because you
need to you need to if I sell customers
for $11,000 a month and I have an
employee who cost me $4,000 per month
and each employee can handle 10
customers that means each employee
handles $10,000 per month for 10
customers so now all we have to do is
say what is our gross margin we're going
to take the
$10,000 we're going to subtract $4,000
from it and that gives us $6,000 per
month gross profit which you'll
sometimes hear expressed as a percentage
which would be 60% gross margins both of
these are the same thing one is an
absolute number the other percentage you
see seeing how $4,000 is my cost this is
how much I make subtract the two that
gives you the margin and that gives you
the percentage now remember we figured
out what our lifetime was and we figure
out how much we make per customer or how
many months they stayed in that instance
now we combine those two metrics to get
the one lifetime gross profit earlier we
did the 10% chur example and so let's
say that these customers stay on average
for 10 months because this is for 10
customers we can divide this by 10 which
gets us $600 per month per customer so I
just div ided the $6,000 bu the 10
customers to get my how much do I make
per customer per month so that's $600
per month per customer in gross profit
now we said earlier that they're staying
for 10 months which means that my
lifetime gross profit per customer is
$6,000 of LT GP so now I know that
customers are worth $6,000 so this is
important because now this is all the
money I have to go spend to acquire them
and run the rest of the business this is
probably one of the biggest mistakes
that business owners make because what
they do is they look at their lifetime
Revenue per customer and say oh as long
as it cost me less than that in
advertising I'm making money but I'll
give you an extreme example to point out
why that doesn't work let's say I sell
these for $10 this pen for $10 but it
cost me $9 and the average person buys
10 pens so it's $100 in Revenue but it
costs me $90 to sell the 100 but if my
team comes to me and says dude we're
killing it we're spending $50 to get a
$100 sale we should do this all day but
what's really happening I'm actually
spending $50 to make $10 in gross profit
lifetime not a good equation and so you
don't want Revenue to confuse you and
this is like one of the biggest
misunderstandings I see business owners
make which is why sometimes because they
don't know this they don't know why they
can't grow the reason lifetime value and
lifetime gross profit get conflated or
confused is because many of the most
formal businesses that are out there
come from Silicon Valley which almost
exclusively is Tech and software and the
gross profits on software are almost
always close to 100% the two can flate
but for everyday business owners who
have people we have manufacturing we
have inventory we have to pay for stuff
to happen that isn't 100% And so we're
not doing it off Revenue we have to
calculate what our gross profit is
because that's what we run our business
off of so far we got our $6,000 lifetime
gross profit cool so we've got one part
of this equation this video is
incredibly in depth and tactical because
I break down every concept to its
absolute base units so my recommendation
to get the most out of this is to watch
all of the concepts understand them so
you see how they all work together to
ultimately help you invest better and
then come back through and then do each
of the concepts individually so that you
can apply them so now we're going to
talk about how to how much it cost to
acquire a customer this is another one
that people mess up so what a lot of
people do is they just look at how much
it cost them to advertise to figure out
how much it cost them to get a customer
that's partially true but not completely
for two reasons the advertising budget
of you're running paid ads for example
is only one of the many costs that go
into a cry and customer the other issue
is that you're not including the labor
so let's say that we have five employees
that cost in total $50,000 a month
that's the labor and then let's say
we're spending $50,000 a month in
software and advertising like Facebook
ads or Instagram ads that means that our
total cost for as a company is
$100,000 per month for all the customers
that we acquired that month and so then
all we do is you look back and say okay
how many do we acquire over the last 30
days let's say this
$100,000 bought us 83 customers so our
cost to acquire customer would be
100,000 divid 83 survey says
$1,224 so this divided by that equals
$1,224 cost to acquire a customer let's
look at our math if if we have cost us
$1,224 to acquire our customer and that
customer makes us $6,000 in lifetime
gross profit we're killing it so that
means that we have a 5:1 ltp to CAC
ratio and if you're like is that good or
is that bad 5 to1 is great you want to
make sure that you're always at least
greater than 3 to one meanings your
lifetime gross profit compared to how
much it cost you to make that money is
at least three times greater otherwise
you'll be too constrained to scale if
this is bad I'm just not I don't need to
look at anything else I can just
automatically toss the business out and
if this is exceptional I might be
willing to overlook or forgive some
other metrics that are coming down the
line that aren't as strong but if you
don't know these numbers in a business
that you're buying or investing or
business that you own find them out so I
told you earlier that I was going to
give you seven well it turns out that uh
that was three of them because the ratio
is one gross profit is another and CAC
is another so we covered three we're
already almost halfway there so number
four is return on invested Capital all
right what we're looking at is how much
money does it cost us to expand the
business there are some businesses like
an accounting firm for example that the
way that they expand the business is
that they just hire more accountants
there really isn't a lot of what they
call Capital expenses which is why I
tend to like service businesses now on
the flip side if I was in manufacturing
i' would have to factor in all the
machines a new location another buildout
that would go into expanding our
capacity to make more stuff whatever
business you have and I do a lot of
brick-and-mortar stuff I want to know
first what's the LT GP to CAC ratio at
the customer level but then how much
does it cost me to make a location and
scale it so for example let's say I have
to put $100,000 in to open each new
location now underneath of that $100,000
is going to be the marketing budget to
launch the location the cost to do the
buildout hiring staff recruiters if we
need that ads for Craigslist to you know
get new people in everything is included
because once you do this enough times
you do have a pretty good idea of what
that number is and you say cool it cost
us $100,000 to open each new location
and at month 6 we're here at 12 months
we're here and at X months we're at
capacity the question is first how
quickly do I make my money back which is
the payback period Then what is my
one-year return and then what am I
making once it's at capacity cuz I want
to know how much cash flow this thing
kicks off and so in this example I love
to see at least 3:1 ideally 5 to1
meaning if I put $100,000 in once we're
at capacity we're at 500,000 per year in
profit I put $1 in I get $5 out and so
this is the same concept as what we're
doing here but just at scale so I'm not
buying one customer I'm buying a custom
printing machine how much does it cost
me to build another machine that creates
profit every single year and so from a
returns perspective if I can pay my
investment back for example in 6 months
after that everything's gravy the part
that people don't want to to talk about
is that all of this stuff cost headspace
right which is that you have an
opportunity cost associated with any
investment meaning what could you have
done with the same level of effort and
money in the same period of time but if
at month 6 I'm breaking even and at
month 12 I'm at let's say pacing 250,000
a year and by the second year I'm at
500,000 a year in profit then great this
is now a node that just kicks off cash
flow year after year after year and then
I think okay well I have $500,000 what
am I going to do open five more
locations if something costs very little
and makes me a lot good now you might be
like well the stock market gets 10%
returns that would be putting $100,000
in and getting $10,000 back I actually
really like to see at least I mean
really 3 to one which means a 300%
return per year kind of at minimum which
sounds ridiculous but I'm putting time
and effort in so these are not passive
Investments for me it's different if I
give someone cash and they do all the
work and then I just get dividends then
that's different but if I'm actively
working then I have to account for all
the time that I'm putting into this and
so for me I want to make sure that I
have a really strong return profile to
justify the cost of time so there's two
big variables that come into fast or
slow payback period one is how much is
this build out right if you have a
massive buildout sometimes it going to
be hard to pay that back quickly the
second is how good they are at launching
somebody might have five locations but
not really have a new location strategy
for a new city so this happens a lot in
brick and mortar chains where they've
got five locations in one city and they
can they can drive to all of them but
then really want to expand and going
from 5 to 20 is a totally different game
now mind you that's what we specialize
in but you now have to go to a new
market where no one knows you and
actually have a launch strategy that
ideally and this is what we like to do
fill up the facility so I want to get to
this capacity as fast as humanly
possible and sometimes that means hey
you guys have a a $10,000 budget for
opening let's put 40 into opening so
that we're opening full and then we're
already at 500,000 a year run rate by
month 6 so if you're a brick and Mort
business by the way and you would like
to scale go to acquisition. comom and to
be clear this is for businesses that are
doing at least a million dollar a year
in profit ideally 3 to five so let's go
through number five which is payback
period simply put how quickly are you
paid back for getting a new customer so
we talked about return on invested
Capital at the business level but now
I'm going all the way back down to the
unit of how long does it take me to
recover the cost you acquire a customer
remember said CAC was $600 if I spend
$600 how quickly do I get it back and so
if you had two scenarios one scenario
where it takes you 3 months to get your
$600 back versus another uh scenario
where you put $600 in and get $66,000 in
the first 30 days which one would you
rather have well if both of them have
the same lifetime gross profit you'd
rather get the money sooner that number
of how long it takes me to get paid back
is G indicator of how cash flow positive
the business is for the big fancy
investors they don't care about as much
because they're working with these
massive companies and long payback
cycles and all this stuff but small
business owners that's how you live and
that's how you expand what we try and do
when we're looking at a business is okay
what is the payback period and are there
some easy levers that we can do to drive
it Forward I'll give you a couple easy
ones so number one is I could say hey
with that example we gave it was $11,000
a month could we just get them to pay
first and last month up front that' be
an easy way to drive drag some of that
cash flow forward and I could break even
and make my payback period 1 month a
second way to do that would be some sort
of fee which is I say hey I have an
onboarding fee enrollment fee an
Initiation fee a setup fee but the point
is that you charge a fee of some sort in
addition to whatever the recurring
revenue is third way to do it is you
could have an upsell of some sort this
is structured as a fee the other is an
upsell this one is optional this one is
mandatory functionally they're the same
thing we're trying to drag more Revenue
up front a fourth way you could do this
is that you could get financing in place
right so you get a third-party bank or
financing partner who says I would like
to make interest on some of these
payments that you have with your
business I will front you the whole
amount that this person owes you but I'm
going to take a piece for taking on the
risk and so you basically give your risk
away to somebody else they take a fee
for that and then you get cash up front
four easy ways that you can think about
to try and decrease your payback period
and in other words get more cash faster
if we're looking at this from a timeline
perspective so $1,200 was the cost to
acquire if we spread that out the first
month I get 600 so I'm still at negative
600 and then I have another 600 that
comes at month two so now I'm at zero so
it took me two months to break even in
the second scenario I add a fee let's
say another $600 and it's just
processing fee I cost me nothing to do
this all right so now my first
transaction I make $1,200 back and I'm
already at breaking even at zero and
then here I get my 600 but I'm plus 600
now and so this business is a healthier
business that will be more adaptable
more resilient in a downturn than this
one let's do number six six and seven
are real short and then I'll give you a
bonus one number eight so these are all
about predictions so up to this point
we've gotten a steady state of okay this
is what the business is is 6 7even and 8
are all about what it can do in the
future okay so number one that I love
this one is sales velocity times
lifetime gross profit which means how
many units are we selling per month
times what are these people going to be
worth to me over the lifetime now you
can also do this as LTV as well because
that's also a good metric to at least
understand especially if sometimes
margins can improve with scale so that
can be helpful to just know both let's
say that I sell 100 customers a month
times $6,000 in in lifetime gross profit
and it was $10,000 in lifetime value
right which is how much revenue they're
going to generate remember because we
still had all the cost Associated the
nice thing with this is that we can see
especially with this one where the
revenue of the business is going to be
at scale because especially if you have
a recurring Revenue business it might
take time for them for the business to
actually get to its hypothetical Max and
so the Assumption here is that if
nothing else changes in the business
they don't sell more customers and the
customers don't become worth any more
than they already are where will this
business even out and so in this example
$1 million a month now this is why this
is so important if someone comes to me
and they're doing 500,000 a month and
they have these metrics then I know that
the business is going to double without
doing anything which is great on the
flip side if a company comes to me and
has these metrics which it still could
and is doing $2 million a month then I
know that it's going to shrink means
that they were either selling more units
earlier on in the past and think
something happened their Facebook ads
got shut down uh they got a bad rap on
their content or and this is probably
the more common one their delivery
started to drop and so their turn
started to increase and so their
lifetime values actually dropped per
customer because they couldn't scale
well and so I can say even though you're
at 2 million a month right now if things
keep going the way they are it's
actually going to go drop down to a
million a month all right and so this
gives you a really good idea of a
snapshot of where someone's going to be
versus where they are so you might be
wondering how can the lifetime value of
a customer change for a business will if
turn goes from 5% to 10% then it means
you cut your lifetime Revenue in half
tough but that's why turn numbers in
retaining customers are so important
because if you go from 10% turn to 5%
you also double the lifetime revenue of
a customer and so this is why the health
of the business based on what its
hypothetical Max is can change and so
the longer period of time you take the
average over realistically the more
accurate it'll be if you did this on a
daily basis it would be really volatile
in smaller businesses smaller businesses
are volatile and so it's good to have
snapshots of okay well what was it
trailing 90 trailing 6 months trailing
12 months to get a much better idea and
you can calculate this at each of those
and then you can look at all three and
say okay well this is what I think it
really is and all of this helps you ask
better questions as an investor so I'm
going to give you the next one which is
very similar to this one which is sales
velocity divided by churn so churn
remember we defined this earlier at the
beginning number of customers and let's
say it's 10% per month okay is the
number of customers who leave and let's
say again we've got 100 customers in
terms of sales
velocity this means that our
hypothetical Max in terms of logos or
number of customers that the that the
business is going to have to sustain or
maintain is going to be a th000
customers now remember we have 1,000
customers remember was paying $1,000 a
month million doll a month these
calculations work together this tells me
how much money are we going to be making
when we're at our hypothetical Max and
this tells me how many customers are we
going to have to be servicing at our
hypothetical Max we're coming down and I
say well dude right now you have the
infrastructure to maintain 2,000
customers but we're going to be at 1,000
you're going to have to be looking at
headcount which sucks on the flip side
if we've got 500 customers we're doing
500,000 a month and I know we're going
to get to 1,000 I might say hey how
could we scale and make sure that we
don't break on our way to a th000
because we're going to get there in X
months that's six and seven and now
we'll go to bonus number eight the
secret bonus which wraps all of this
stuff together this equation is really
in relation to how big the opportunity
is so Tam is just a fancy word for total
adjustable Market which is how many
people could I potentially sell and so
when I'm analyzing an opportunity it's
number of potential units times lifetime
gross profit divided by risk and so this
ultimately gets at how big of a company
do I think this could ultimately be if
we're servicing you know vegan moms with
three kids who like powerlifting then
there might only be 50,000 of them and
so I'm going to have 50,000 potential
units sold that's assuming we get 100%
of the market to buy now that might not
be true but that would be here is what's
what how many could we potentially sell
the lifetime gross profit is well how
much do we make on all of these people
this would give us an idea of how big
the opportunity is this is all the good
stuff the big question is How likely is
that going to happen risk has a zillion
categories so that's beyond the scope of
this video but do I think that there's a
trend are there going to be more vegan
powerlifting moms in the future are
there going be less vegan powerlifting
moms in the future so for example right
now I am looking at fertility stuff tons
of people are having fertility issues I
think it's going to be a booming Market
in the future so something that Services
anything related to fertility will
probably have big Tailwinds behind it
you can apply risk to each of these so
from selling potential units is okay is
the way that we're acquiring customers
something that's really risky are there
going to be platforms that are going to
change do we expect that this method of
getting customers is sustainable is
there key man risk is there's somebody
who's in charge of that department that
if they left would' be screwed right all
of these are factors of risk of How
likely it is to happen in the future
from the lifetime gross Prosper
perspective are there other competitors
that could come in and undercut us how
strong is our position in the
marketplace do we have a better product
that can sustain a premium are there
economies of scale that we can have or
there is there shrinking margins which
sometimes can happen at scale and so
these are all risks that could affect
our gross profit per customer over the
long haul some people might think okay
well how how important is Tam it is
extremely important but the ability to
assess it is very limited this is one of
those uh important and unknown uh which
Charlie merer and Warren Buffett talk
about a lot which is like you've got
things that are knowable and unknowable
and unimportant and important and we
just want to focus on the knowable and
important the economy and interest rates
very important is it knowable no so they
don't try to predict it with Tam I see
it kind of in that very important but
not knowable and here's why the amount
of companies that start with a niche and
then expand and expand and redefine
their customer redefine their Avatar
most businesses have especially the
biggest ones Amazon started as a
bookstore now it's an everything store
Facebook started as a social network for
college kids and then became the
everything social network and so many
huge examples start small because they
want to narrowly to find a problem for a
specific Avatar and they expand over
time but the main point for this one is
how much risk am I exposed to that is
knowable that I think could potentially
break this equation from working in the
future when you take the first seven and
you plug that into this framework for
assessing value or how big this could
potentially be then you have a very good
framework to analyze a business yourself
or others to potentially invest in or
say I'm a no on this one dog and by the
way if you don't have something like
this I'd recommend just put one s sheet
together that tracks your numbers
automatically every month because you'll
get a much better idea of how your
business is doing from a health
perspective again if you're a brick and
mortar chain doing a million dollars in
profit per year or more and you've got a
sound model and you want to expand we're
looking for you right now we've done
super well with brick and mortar chains
expanded really really big and we're
just looking for awesome businesses that
we can get involved in so specifically
service based businesses million plus
ideally 3 to 5 million in profit so if
that's you reach out to us we can make
it rain together